this is a baby cuban crocodile one of  the rarest crocs in the world  hidden away in only two parts of cuba  they have the smallest range of any croc  species  the cuban crocodile is critically  endangered experts say approximately 3  000 remain in the wild  its bright pebbled scales set it apart  from other crocodiles  they favor freshwater lakes and swamps  rarely venturing into the  ocean they're strong swimmers using  their powerful tails to thrust out of  the water catching prey hiding in  overhanging branches  habitat degradation hunting and  interbreeding with related crocodile  species all pose threats this is a cuban  crocodile